j'accueille ingrid pedersen lennon
john lennon avait une soeur cachée c'est
vous mettez à fille de julia giulia qui
était une épicurienne qui aimait prendre
du bon temps femme très joli mais qui
trompait allègrement son mari alfred
lennon le père de john qui avait le tort
d'être marin quand julia est enceinte de
vous alfred son mari est en mer et pour
éviter le scandale
elle vous confie ingrid à un couple
d'amis les pedersen dont l'homme peder
pedersen et sans doute votre père en
fait vous avez été adopté par votre
propre père d'une certaine façon
exactement les époux pederson faut
modifier votre état civil
vous devenez ingrid pedersen donc vous
êtes voilà vous disparaissez en tant que
fille de julian lennon
il ne vous parlent jamais du passé vous
passez donc les 11 premières années de
votre vie un liverpool à deux pas de
votre frère john lennon et de votre mère
julian lennon mais le silence est
assourdissant
vous commencez à éprouver de drôles de
sensations j'avais un sentiment confus
que quelque chose ne colle pas et un
jour vous demandez à votre mère si vous
êtes une enfant adoptée elle m'a dit non
elle ne m'a pas dit que j'étais adopté
ouais alors les pedersen décide de
s'installer dans le kent et là vous
devenez une fan d'elvis presley caf ne
sachant pas que vous êtes la soeur de
jeunes ménages
vous adorez elvis presley les beatles
vous en foutez en fait c'est vrai je
préférais vis mais hélas dans le kent ne
sera pas très bien où fumer votre
première cigarette à l'âge de 7 ans vous
buvez votre première votre qu'à l'âge de
12 ans bientôt vous ajouterez les
tranquillisants en réponse à des crises
de panique ça faisait des crises
d'angoissé très très grave
sans savoir pourquoi en fait à ce
moment-là j'ai beaucoup de tension je
n'étais pas heureuse
j'étais dans une famille adopté il
régnait une grande tension
je savais qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui ne tourne pas rond savais pas ce que
c'était exactement puisque ma mère
adoptive ne me l'a pas dit elle ne m'en
a pas parlé elle ne rien expliquer alors
vous rencontrez un homme vous décidez de
vous marier mais il vous faut un acte de
naissance dont vous écrivez à la mairie
de liverpool qui ne connaît aucune
ingrid pedersen
et pour cause et à ce moment là votre
mère vous révèle que vous avez été
adoptée et que vous êtes la soeur de
john lennon à ce moment là pourquoi
est-ce que vous n'allez pas voir john
lennon quand vous savez le jour où vous
apprenez vous êtes sa soeur pourquoi est
ce que vous n'avez pas le voir je me
suis allé parce que je ne pouvais pas
j'aurais fait une promesse un serment à
ma mère des petits folie avait dit que
je ne chercherai pas john parce que ça
lui ferait trop de mains ouais et je ne
pouvais pas lui faire ça voilà donc vous
n'en parlez plus à partir de là c'est
fini vous en parler plus jamais avec
votre mère nous n'aurons plus jamais
interdit alors pourtant john lennon vous
cherche un
il cherche à retrouver sa soeur
me chercher il me chercher sous le
mauvais est ce le mauvais certificat en
essence parce que les deux avaient été
changés voilà et pourtant à cette époque
john lennon est présent partout et
toujours dans les radios dans les dents
dans les journaux vous commencez à lire
tout ce qui a été écrit sur lui vous
vous préparer pour une rencontre à ce
moment là vous vous pensez que vous
allez l'appeler aller le voir
oui j'espérais faire cela je n'ai jamais
pensé qu'il pouvait être assassiné je
voulais rencontrer je voulais rencontrer
mon frère et tous mais toute ma famille
mais je n'ai pas pu le faire à cause de
chapman qui l'a assassiné
et ça vous la prenez un soir à 19 heures
en regardant la télévision
vous êtes seul dans votre salon et on
annonce l'assassinât de john lennon par
mark chapman et là vous vous dites que
ce frère que vous n'avez jamais vu vous
le verrez jamais plus j'étais tout seul
était dans une autre pièce à la même
maison elle est entrée dans le salon
vu les infos à la télévision tout ce
qu'elle dit c'est pauvre gars est sorti
de la pièce c'est tout ce qu'elle a dit
à ce sujet et le jour vous apprenez la
mort de john lennon les journaux
télévisés parle de sa mère julian lennon
et vous apprenez en même temps que la
mort de votre frère la mort de votre
mère biologique qui est décédé en 1958
un accident de voiture alors qu'il avait
45 ans et l on a décidé petit à petit il
mourrait l'un après l'autre tous les
membres de ma famille et je n'ai pas pu
rencontrer qui que ce soit permis tout
ce que je voulais rencontrer
voilà
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'à la mort de votre mère
adoptive madame pedersen donc que vous
déciderez de lever le secret sur votre
sur votre origine à partir de là vous
n'avez plus aucun problème pour en
parler tout à coup je me suis trouvée
libre libre de faire ce que je voulais
faire depuis des années finalement même
est toujours considérée comme une enfant
elle ne m'a jamais laissé grandir et
tout à coup je me suis retrouvé avec le
monde devant ma la possibilité de faire
tout ce que je voulais et je les fais
j'ai fait quelque chose que je
souhaitais faire depuis des années alors
quelques années plus tard yoko ono vous
invite à new york
vous y allez elle vous montre l'endroit
qui s'appelle strawberry fields ou l'est
où les fans de lennon viennent déposer
des gerbes de fleurs en sa mémoire
et quand vous les voyez vous comprenez
que vous avez pas grand chose à voir
avec ces gens là finalement je n'avais
pas un chose à voir avec elle en tout
cas elle m'appelait un jour et qu on m a
dit qu elle voudrait me rencontrer et
donc
invitée à new york j'avais rencontré
dakota building ou john elle vivait puis
elle m'a amené ce très beau fils hans
backe
et puis elle m'a montré les endroits où
jeanne elle allait se promener
je ne suis resté que deux jours dans
c'était intéressant mais vous avez quand
même eu le sentiment d'avoir raté
également ce rendez vous là non la
possibilité de parler yoko autant que
j'aurais mais j'aurais voulu avec à voir
avec elle une conversation a vraiment
intime isner n'a pas été possible
[Musique]
elle avait toujours un chapeau avec elle
et contrôler à la fois des questions les
réponses
et donc c'était très difficile de parler
avec elle finalement là aujourd'hui vous
vivez en france
vous vivez en mayenne avec un homme qui
s'appelle john comme votre frère que
vous avez rencontrés quand vous étiez
toute petite à l'école à liverpool
quand on se connaît depuis puis autant
que je me souvienne il s'est marié de
son côté je me suis marié et puis on ne
s'est plus vu pendant un temps et nous
nous sommes retrouvés
c'est comme ça que ça laisse faire c'est
une histoire extraordinaire non imagine
imaginez vous auriez pas préféré être la
soeur de paul mccartney finalement si
vous aviez été la soeur de ringo starr
vous l'auriez pas d'y répondre à cette
question est-ce que vous avez droit à
l'héritage de john lennon je n'ai aucun
droit
est ce que vous voyez julian lennon le
fils de john a eu avec sa première femme
rencontrée au nigeria nation
j'adorais les rencontres ils sont mes
neveux après tout ils ont vécu des vies
sera différente de la mienne
puis c'est une autre génération aussi
ils ne comprennent pas qu'on prenne pas
le pas c'est mon frère
paris milite pedersen bénin
éditions michel lafon et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus